what's up guys bang bang Bitcoin having
a little bit of a Down week it's up 70
to start the year but it is down seven
percent this past week but that's okay
because bitcoin's hash rate continues to
hit all-time high after all-time high we
also see Bitcoin on chain wallet
addresses whether it's 280 2 800 or 28
000 of Bitcoin they all continue to hit
all-time highs that is global adoption
trending upwards and the security of the
network also trending upwards even
though price came down a little bit over
the past week now there's two major
stories that I want to pay attention to
this past week the first Terra wolf
using the Nautilus crypto mine they have
officially launched a 50 megawatt Mining
facility now there's a little bit of a
Twist to this specific facility this is
the first us-based nuclear powered
Bitcoin mining facility in history that
is a major deal there's over 91 percent
of the energy used is zero carbon and
they continue you to watch that Nautilus
crypto mine facility serve as an example
with the hope that many other nuclear
power plants around the world will begin
to use the Bitcoin miners as a way to
monetize some of that power now I know I
can't say the word nuclear but at least
you've got that news the other big story
is coinbase has officially been approved
for a derivatives Exchange in Bermuda
this is becoming more of a story because
coinbase has come out and said that they
are open to all possibilities when it
comes to where they are domicile
obviously coinbase is a publicly traded
company here in the United States they
were started almost a decade ago and
they continued to try to comply with all
regulations both domestically and
internationally but they are complaining
about how much lack of regulatory
Clarity there is in the United States
and so they are now seeking to
understand what their options may be
internationally I don't know whether
coinbase is going to stay in the US or
whether they're going to move but I do
know that if they were to move that
would be a very big deal we also saw in
the recent hearing of the house
Financial committee that actually there
was the CCP making an announcement that
they wanted to open up their banking
apparatus to be more receptive to
us-based crypto companies with the hope
to capitalize on the abrasive nature of
the current regulations for this
industry again that wouldn't be good
either so whether it's something like
more minors coming online and using new
forms of power or it's coinbase getting
more International approvals and trying
to understand where they're going to be
domiciled and where they're going to
continue to go ahead and execute we need
to continue to pay attention because
although the price of Bitcoin is still
more than 50 percent lower than its
previous all-time high we continue to
see all sorts of development and new
all-time highs and underlying
fundamentals Bitcoin has never been this
secure and Bitcoin has never been this
adopted on a global basis both of those
two things tend to serve great for the
long-term Trend and as we see in value
investing in public equities and various
other asset classes at some point value
and price meet the question is will
price appreciate to meet value or will
value have to come down to meet price
your guess is as good as mine but as
we've seen over the long run it tends to
be that price eventually discovers what
value has been built in the preceding
months and years that's it for this
week's update I hope you enjoy these and
I'll see you next Saturday